this podcast is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon who are the sole
reason that we are able to do another
episode in person they also got this
episode ad free early and with less
editing thanks to patreon we will also
be creating another idiots and a broad
vlog which will be available exclusively
on patreon this month so please if you
want to support the show and get extra
content go to patreon.com
huge thank you to everybody who is
already supporting the show hi everyone
welcome to another episode of idiots and
abroad i'm alana that's jacob that's
raffle that's john look at me i'm in
wide angle what are you so unsure about
john what heat level do you want the
tenders
the chicken candies mild or medium hot
extra hot or
like grim reaper i get it it has a
disclaimer for a reaper
it says see disclaimer below yeah what's
the disclaimer probably extra hot
that um
[Music]
what do you think
[Music]
[Laughter]
people are laughing at inside jokes that
you've all missed you just sourced me
six i vetted six jokes
and chose none of them and just panicked
that's great um yeah so we're in
l.a everybody yeah we are yeah
uh john's here so we can play elden
rings
by the way i'm ordering chicken tenders
for all of us yes uh it is wide angle
which is why we all love
extra wide well rocco and i look look
thick yeah she's going to be on noise
[Music]
oh the heat i put it mild
the filipino jumped out and wants medium
speaking i turned the ac on and everyone
[ __ ] yelled at me and now i'm over
here sweating into your chair look how
cozy we all are you know that you got
nice if i were to take my underwear off
there would be a thick
dark spot all up the back you shot
yourself
because yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what i was saying
yeah that's what it was that's the thing
three mediums and one mild
okay
right before starting this recording i
walked up a very steep hill
that was like two hours ago at this
point my one of my legs hurt so bad
what are sharp pains in my knees i was
outside yesterday
uh with lawrence omar and steph
um
and uh we went to sherman oaks
bless you
i would like anybody to know that we're
not drunk
i just started yeah everybody's body is
like falling apart right now without
happening we went to sherman oaks castle
park
and we played arcade games and then we
did mini golf and then we did batting
cages what sounds dude and then i got
home and i said i think i'm gonna die
because i was standing up in the sun for
more than 15 minutes yeah
yeah we used to um i don't celebrate it
anymore but when i did celebrate
australia day it's during the day and
it's always a public holiday and it's in
the summer because it's january in
australia
everybody just gets hammered during the
day listening to this thing called uh
triple j i think it's like top 40 top
100 it's top 100 so it's just like top
100 songs of the year and you try to
make it to number one i passed out
almost every year before the first time
just just because you're day drinking in
a pool and it's hot but god i miss that
about australia christmas day is like
that too you just get really drunk in a
pool and it's the best
of the river
i've seen some rivers yeah the rebar
several well that's it that's the thing
here down in san diego it's like east of
san diego i don't remember where it was
i got blindfolded and taken there so i i
can't tell you where what
but uh
there's a river you go tubing
okay
it was a surprise oh they surprised you
with a ribbon yeah okay
that's cool and the best part was that
it was uh you know you we
trekked up river in the water
far
uh and then coming back down i just laid
and i slithered like an otter all the
way down because there would be rocks
with little falls and i just
slither over them
it was awesome that does sound dumb like
that's one of my favorite experiences
was slithering down a river
yeah people used to do like a drink and
get in a floaty thing in the brisbane
river back home but uh
they're a floaty thing yeah they just
like get drink beers and be in like a
tube thing or you buy you buy a box of
wine you take it out of the box because
it's just a giant sack of wine
so it floats
you call that again slap it you call it
a what a goon bag a goon bag that's what
it's called in a stream
you hang them from a clothesline because
we have uh hills voice clotheslines in
australia which spin
you hang them from a clothesline with a
peg and then you spin them and then
whoever it lands on drinks
that's what teenagers would do that
sounds really common
you should do that i want a goon bag
yeah that's basically just any cheap
like bag of wine um how many chicken
tindies are you ordering dude
he's looking at pictures
do you think pictures of chicken
i had the wrong addressing
so i was placing an order for it to
arrive at mine yeah not realizing that i
hadn't put in your address i've done
that before yeah so
i've had to cancel and restart
i did that when i was in another city i
don't know why i said it like it was
complicated i've done that because it's
just fun it bummed me out all right yeah
yeah that's okay
i forgive you but now it's it's that i
can still order from the same place
but the um
it's gonna be cold when it gets here
because i'm not compromising
okay that's why it's going to be spicy
because it takes too long yeah spicy to
go from where i am how about a feeding
tray to [ __ ] calabasas a heating tray
calabasas you mean that's real far
this
you accidentally found that drawer
earlier yeah somehow the dog opened it
and it was great a draw how handy okay
we're all talking over each other we're
so excited i want to know
what one of you has been up to since we
recorded the last part it's not in your
[ __ ] business
oh
what have i done anything that's
intrusive no i feel like you're the one
who's done on the travel yeah i've just
come from i don't know
yeah but you're always there
all right what happened in canada mate
nothing can't talk about it
you met mark hamill
uh
yeah mark uh he told a story of
mark campbell
that's the story i can't remember
his first audition
or something his age he was telling us
uh misheard him and it was mark mar
campbell
mark campbell mark campbell uh have you
started planting the seeds to make him
hate jacob
it's backfired oh
if you go on mark's social media he
gives me [ __ ]
i mean i'm not going to put you on the
spot yeah but what was it like to meet
him for the first time yes we circle
back after i've ordered the chicken
can't do both the ones too exciting a
little bit
and also i'm doing this so that the same
people that for some reason get upset
with my energy i was just like i would
like to point out that i directed
questions to you because when i went
you're the only one who's traveled
you rahul went i've been in [ __ ]
canada so i asked you questions and you
like can you [ __ ] wait until i put in
my chicken
i don't know what i'm supposed to do
yeah because we us la folks just been
working that's kind of it oh i haven't
been working for [ __ ] sake slap them
jacob slap him slap him right on the
knee i've been doing a lot of things
you have i came out here for a super
bowl it's like a little baby's head
coming out yes hey oh my god i went to
the super bowl you went to the super
bowl yeah okay so i went to a super bowl
what
nothing i was buttering to myself tell
us about your super bowl party about
sitting next to you is that i can't see
your facial expressions all the time i'm
just well while other people talk i'll
just have to look at jacob
pretty often just get a scoop of it i
know i feel like we should project
ourselves onto a zoom call so that we
can just look at each other's corners
yeah um i went to a super bowl party i
was only gonna fly out for three days
and then
alana was like i'm getting elden ring
the day after you fly out and i was like
well [ __ ] i'm going to extend my flight
and then on the day after i flew out
alana was like never mind i'm not
getting it until the day before you fly
out from the flight that you will be
getting any minute now
yeah maybe we'll see yeah i could be so
excited yeah i'm so excited um so i've
been here for no reason doing nothing
you've done so much i streamed from your
setup
i streamed from fun house
where
for some reason
um
every like
how i was set up
i couldn't see anyone coming in and the
headphones were too good
so i think i think i encountered it six
times people came in
and four of the six times they scared
the living [ __ ] out of how did that
happen yeah lizzy and i came in we saw
we both peeked around the corner and
johnny were just playing seafood i was
expecting it and then it still scared
the share of me the first one the very
first one was omar is it about that room
that would blindside you because that's
the multi-camera yeah i don't know
you're in the farthest corner omar
literally came in and put his head right
here
and i still didn't notice and then i saw
in chat everyone was going ha ha
i tried to do that in my office but it
failed yeah i tried to sneak up and you
were like hey that was cool
because you came in stomping with your
big ass feet i'm just too thick you know
i can't help myself because it's a
problem yeah are you too jacob you know
you got those games yeah you're gonna
make me act up jacob
okay i'll let you lock the side oh
that's very nice i'll let you the
comments decide democratic wow this is
also this is the first time i've been in
a place where you live
and i'm really surprised the fact that
you have all this space you have all
these cool figures and stuff but every
single picture on the wall is a framed
picture of you
everywhere yeah i'm just covering them
this whole thing we've cropped it out
but it's just pictures yeah we took them
all down because we thought it would be
weird for the podcast people would be
confused about this speaking i didn't
know you had beef curtains
he just said we took them down
that's not true there is no art on the
walls except for one about
unsurprisingly
she looks like a prison i thought you
would defend the other thing that wasn't
true
what makes that's the bit that you're
like
don't hang up yeah what's that true
about it
there is no no i'm having trouble with
that
facts that we did
so the walls are just real white and i
need to figure out which ones i'm going
to paint and like i've got a sword
hanging up over there and i just got a
new sword
and we scoped out some aunt arrived i
don't know i'm figuring it out slowly um
john's been visiting you you're a great
houseguest thank you you cook and clean
that's all i cook and clean
yeah you did ask it was pretty weird if
you could fold my laundry one time
though so
like that no you put my laundry in your
laundry so then i was like i'll just
hold it all yeah and then you you told
me to leave
[Laughter]
does ryan know that you two are dating
oh [ __ ]
this is mango i thought it was just
tangerine i did go to the i feel like i
should clarify that first we did laundry
and john was like oh you want me to fold
it and as i already did it it wasn't
weird he was very polite um in any case
yeah i went to the super bowl with ryan
ryan haley yeah so
we got cheap goslin
girlfriend he's probably there too uh i
managed to get cheap tickets by like
waiting really long and then i did it
through like a raffle type thing so not
the publicly listed prices because it's
[ __ ] absurd but it was still
expensive
and i took ryan with me because i was
like well i want to go with someone who
can't afford to pay for their ticket but
also that would like have a good time oh
because i could take somebody who knows
[ __ ] nothing about
football yeah cool yeah but he i knew
how hyped he was and i was like it would
be dope if i take ryan so we had a
really really good time it was super fun
the favorite like
aside from you know getting to see it
all in person the halftime show [ __ ]
sucks in person you couldn't hear or see
anything well they also the whole set
was designed with like tv eight walls
and there there was inside like living
rooms so only like 20 of the stadium
could see on one side what was happening
yeah what angle did you have on that um
okay say the like houses were like like
there we were looking at it from sort of
up here yeah yeah like the corner yeah
so it was ryan
we were all the super bowl party and
ryan sent us a picture and james was
just laughing showing it to everyone
so wait can you see dr dre like
pushing buttons and stuff we could see
that there were people on top of the
building
but i couldn't have told you who they
were whereas when we were watching
the game being played it's a lot easier
because you can see the numbers yeah um
so we could see the super bowl itself
fine halftime show audio was so bad and
we also got this email ahead of time
that was like hey uh maybe bring
earplugs because when the game ends
there will be oh sorry when the halftime
show ends there will be this extremely
loud sound
um that will play very close to where
you're sitting and
halftime show ends we get fireworks and
this really loud beep
because i guess it's like the audio
switching back over to
yeah
oh [ __ ] that seems like an oversight
a silver email that's gonna happen
easier way to do that
i don't know it's sifu stadium right is
it seafood stadium yeah oh seafood it's
super cool stadium so far they've got a
stadium already
yeah game just came out holy [ __ ] shout
out to slow clap french people got a
stadium
wait seafood's made by french people
yeah it's french off me i know
devastating um dog game though we've
been playing i made jon watch me uh play
the second level and just restart every
time i died for a few hours
because i wanted to get through without
dying at all yeah and you're really bad
at the game that's not true
you know that's not true you're much
better than me thank you you are very
good it's really we have witnessed
remember i got very into it really
quickly but yeah super bowl was [ __ ]
awesome my favorite thing was
uh walking
back from it like because obviously
whenever you go to something like that
there's a ton of people you have to
avoid all of the people to be able to
leave
um any time that we saw
a little kid with a ranch shirt we'd go
whose house and they'd go fantastic
so stoked about it like there was a kid
in a car we were like whose house and he
was like
it was super super cute like seeing
little kids just like lose their [ __ ]
money
you're doing a fool's house instead of a
who day yeah [ __ ] that who day
day bengals bengals i didn't know they
say
bang bang yeah
i i was going to say what the rest of it
was like like
something kind of it's like who day
is or something i didn't know there was
more i thought people just yelled who
day no i think it's who they
think
them
yeah nobody
like that
oh there we go yeah the bengals classic
death stranded
yeah
our first friend i'm still curious why
it's called the bagels like the bengals
do they are bagels invented in
cincinnati why do you keep saying bagels
it's a bit he's doing a bit no i'm not
he's doing a bit it is time to talk
about the second annual video game
accessibility awards which is taking
place this saturday march 12th at 2 p.m
pacific time on twitch.tv
twitch though it will also be on my
channel at twitch.tv charalanazad if you
want a probably more manageable chat if
you don't know this is an award show
that celebrates advancements in
accessibility in video games and is
hosted by myself and steven spahn and
nominees include games such as before
your eyes unpacking halo infinite far
cry 6 back for blood it takes 2 and
ratchet and clank rift apart plus many
many more today we actually announced
our awards presenters um which includes
ryan reynolds
and some favorites like sweet anita and
no hands and crank gameplays plus a
whole bunch of other really really
wonderful people that we're so excited
to have joining us the whole show is
sponsored by pizza hut a very big thank
you to pizza hut for helping us out and
we expect it to be a combination of a
really fun funny time where we have a
lot of jokes ready for you guys but also
informative so you can come through and
learn more about the world of video game
accessibility and watching in general
would really help us out so we can have
a bigger better show hopefully in person
next year so please do help out by
tuning in to the second annual video
game accessibility awards which takes
place on march 12th at 2 p.m pacific
time they're bengal tigers bagel tigers
yeah
it's like a bagel bite i know what that
looks like
oh but it was dope i had a very good
time
and yeah since john's been here you know
i've been hanging out um i have this
foster dog who's currently asleep in a
crate drugged who's been getting a bit
grumpy at people she's got some problems
because she's a rescue but she's very
sweet um but my favorite thing that
she's done the entire time that i've had
her has been barking at people of color
barking at people who call it yeah no um
it's true
she talked to tara today
because she could smell jacob on her
yeah yeah because she's an interracial
relationship and she has
opinions yeah that's fair she's gone for
me no there was um
john had his pants sitting on the top of
like a closed toilet seat and she just
like walked up to them uh and grabbed
the pants off of the toilet seat and
then dropped them directly
it's awesome she was like and just say
well what and
she's helping and she's helping it was
great does she drink out of that toilet
bowl too she likes drinking out of
toilet bowls yeah the uh was it last
night yeah i was
i was laying in bed and uh alana you
were gone
and i heard
i was like oh i wanna sound and then
hurt
and she had opened the bathroom door to
go in and drink from the toilet yeah
she's pretty small she can open doors
but she does she does have some
behavioral problems she right now she's
just she had died
i heard it
she's just twitching and asleep oh it's
so cute yeah she's super cute did she
[ __ ] on a rug too or something she did
[ __ ] on a rug last night oh by the way i
did because yeah i walked her she didn't
poop and then i went to sleep and i do
remember at one point waking up and
going it kind of smells like [ __ ] and
then going back to sleep
cool thanks for that didn't hear it
happen or anything no no no i just
thought i was like yeah i am i'm so
trained to it's like better than an
alarm clock like like a animal almost
[ __ ] or puking or something near me
when i'm sleeping like but she was down
here yeah oh okay i was asleep in a room
like she yeah i mean i just saw that she
had peed on the office rug i was like oh
what happened just now
at some point today i don't even know
why is it still up there i just put a
bunch of water on it and then hung it
just laid on that rug
why did you lay on that rug
because i thought it didn't have any
piss on it you would have seen it and
smelt it i don't know when she did it
though it's very strange
um it's a lot of work and yeah she
sometimes scrambles of people away stay
at mine jordan she's been through a lot
she has yeah do you want to stay in line
john huh you wanna stay at one i'm down
the strippers don't pee on the couch or
anything how do you know
what how do you know because it's not p
you want to go like 90 10 on a stripper
1910.
don't leave wait
oh no yeah i'm cool
did they do a study isn't it isn't like
when squirting happens isn't it mostly p
yeah that's it no
wait a study i thought i told you that
from an interview with asap rocky and
danny brown did you tell me that yeah
they talked about it did we talk about
this i think so there's this awesome
video from it was like vice's
music channel i forget what it's called
um but they did this thing in vegas
where they just put danny brown and asap
rocky like at a pool together
basically interviewing each other and
just talking
and it's so funny because they're
talking they're like you like the
twitter [ __ ] and he's like i like the
facebook [ __ ] because you get to know
them more you can see their photos and
stuff
um and then they're like have you ever
made it like do you like squirting and
danny travis like
you know it's you always wake up in the
wet spot and it smells like this
i don't remember this conversation oh
it's really funny there's like that's
not funny it was back during like short
youtube video days so there's four parts
and they're each like is it piss punk
i mean i love it i think so it's my
favorite part i mean i'm not i'm not
bothered i don't ever intend to
experience or put enough work to see a
female orgasm
but
academically
that's interesting you're interested in
the science of yeah of a of a female
orgasm alexa when a woman squirts is it
piss
no i'm not going anywhere just get that
one i am good
with that have you all seen that video
where it's the kid it's like a little
three-year-old
and he wants to listen to a song i think
called
digger digger it's about i think it's a
minecraft song
um and he goes alexa
and it goes all right playing [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's like loading video [ __ ] [ __ ]
orgasm
on amazon
she played it there we go
no i have not seen that video oh we can
get
demonetized no that's fine patreon thank
you we appreciate all of you yeah that's
also part of why john's years because
it will already be up by the time that
this is up but i wanted to play through
a bunch of elder ring with john and
jacob i'm so excited we're doing that on
president's day as the president would
want us to you know what's president's
day it's just celebrating george
washington and abraham lincoln or
something isn't what weird what yeah
it's two they're both of their birthdays
are in the i don't [ __ ]
who cares listen we're from america so
we don't know [ __ ] about history yeah
the american education system
specifically avoids history
we just learn how to do things over and
over and over again yeah so that we can
work in factories
from the industrial revolution that's
literally the american school system is
designed
to mansplain to me i think i told you
this hey so
school systems are different than every
country sugar tits listen to them
[Laughter]
which one of those were you talking to
again i'll let the incident decide i
keep gaslighting john regarding
mansplaining well i'm telling him he is
when he's absolutely not and jacob today
uh said that he's been trying out
gaslighting
he said i thought i'd try out gas well i
mean with the god it was me telling you
there's a sandwich on your countertop
that you're like where'd the sandwich
come from but i was just like you put it
there
[Music]
which is that i'm constantly in fear of
mansplaining and also in fear of being
perceived as a pervert
so when
like when you were doing laundry you
were like do you have any clothes you
want to throw and i was like yeah sure
and then when the watch finished i was
like oh i should just move it to the
dryer but then i came down and i was
like alana is it okay if i move the
stuff to the dryer and she was like yeah
i was like it's okay if i touch your
underwear
because
i'm so [ __ ] paranoid about that that
i felt like i needed to get permission
disrespectful yeah that's cool that's
sweet but then also i mansplained to
alana all the time that would have been
and apologize for it it's only p
a lot is this p okay i got two i got two
answers for you i got two answers for
you president's day is officially
washington's birthday
uh in the united states the holidays
popularly recognized as honoring george
washington and abraham lincoln yeah that
[ __ ] all the other presidents i guess
i mean for real
sometimes understood as a celebration of
the birthdays and lives of us presidents
in general um but mostly just
washington and abraham obama
yeah washington lincoln and obama wasn't
there oh it's little wayne
obama obama it was a milly but it was
the obama oh my god
what i was in
obama obama when i was in uh
oklahoma city doing a protest against
tom coburn and that [ __ ] senator uh
there was this homeless guy that came up
with a giant obama shirt and he just
went oh bomb
yo mama no drama and then he rode away
on his bike
anyway the present data based on
ultrasonic
ultrasonographic bladder monitoring and
biochemical analysis indicate that
squirting is essentially the involuntary
emission of a urine
during a sexual activity although a
marginal contribution of prostatic
secretions to the emitted fluid often
exists
there you go so people are getting
excited over just water sports it's just
someone
there once was a woman from ealing who
had a peculiar feeling she lay on her
back spread open a crack and pissed all
over the ceiling wow
did you just make that what is it that
just said that was an original
what is the cream i'm from ealing
what
what the cream yeah
yeah i showed you the yeast infection oh
that's oh yeah i remember now you said
you could make a loaf of bread
i a lot for that video has really
escaped my memory
recently i need another drink i've got
to i'm about to finish this one so bring
me another one just in case researchers
have clapped these cheeks
again
internet
i let them write their narratives
brought women into clinics and got them
to squirt in front of them a 1984 study
found that
54 percent of women have experienced an
orgasmic expulsion of fluid that's much
sicker when you put it that way and
orgasmic expulsion of fluid yeah
prostatic emissions yeah
[ __ ] that is some destiny [ __ ] oh cool
some global warming problem
when a vulva releases a specif
go on one of vulva releases
a specific type of fluid from the
urethra evolving area and respond with
this also demonetized in response to
sexual stimulation you can't say urethra
or evolver this is too sexual that's
what they tend to be monetized
um
the liquid released during squirting is
usually as clear as water colorless and
odorless and it sometimes comes
out oh my god
you haven't woken the dog up somehow
um there is no consensus among sexual
health professionals as to what squat is
thank you thanks
right on the tip it what it contains
some of the same components as urine and
some of the same components as semen wow
what like this
okay everyone google this right now
take
google giant [ __ ]
and then google micro penis oh yeah and
put them next to each other
it's the same well they are based on the
same thing yeah it's the same organ you
get that y chromosome your [ __ ]
grows
into a stem
oh my god i bet you this dude feels
awful about the fact he's so far up on
the search results for micro penis look
he's pretty handsome though he's like
the third picture
no he's proud look how proud he's
staying wait look at his body language
no but it's a it's a what's that what's
that picture next swipe
no top top go back the top one what's
that that's a micro penis microphone i
thought that was a woman no that's what
micro penis does oh that one's bad
that's a bad one it's like licking a
jolly rancher it's just a head
oh my god it's just old head
uncircumcised it makes it look bigger
disclaimer not that there's anything
wrong with no of course not small
generals or oversized generals
listen not at all i think just the
longest
i think people who have
micro penis
understand
that we will laugh at them
it is time to talk about a very normal
podcast tour are you a fan
of this show that you are watching or
listening to right now because we are
actually going to be taking the show
live in person in front of a live
audience i just said a lot of words that
mean the same thing but you get the idea
on march 12th doors open at 6 30 pm pst
and you can come and watch a very normal
podcast tour with the funhouse podcast
and idiots and abroad live in los
angeles tickets are still available i
will leave a link in the description we
would absolutely love to see you there
for our very first live show and
hopefully if it's successful we could
start doing live shows in other cities
as well wouldn't that be cool the cast
attending features armando torres
charlotte mcgraw elise williams jane
williams and ryan haley who you will
know from funhouse as well as me john
smith jacob fulton and rahul kohli from
idiots and abroad we do have a cool
announcement that i haven't even told
the boys about yet that will be taking
place live during the show and if you
aren't able to join us live the audio
from the episode will be published as a
patreon exclusive as soon as we get it
they don't have any video recording so
we can't offer a video version
audio will be on
patreon.com otherwise would really love
to see you there or potentially see you
at a show like this in the future very
big thank you to rooster teeth for
having us no we don't make fun of
anybody's genitals on this show i feel
like i have to give that disclaimer
every episode
listen if you have a micro penis you'll
find love
oh my god i choked a lot of what were we
recording a video or something you said
that women don't care about it
about the size about the size i mean i
think that's probably an extent to that
but generally yeah i would say that's
true okay there are there are realities
okay yeah when strap-ons
you got options yeah you have options
so bad
i don't know how far through we want to
do it but we do also have um some hot
chips yeah we do that i typically bought
for you i'm certain that it will take
at least 10 minutes to like recover and
get back to zero and close it closer to
the end closer to the end yeah yeah yeah
oh okay i made a charcuterie board
that was my phone oh it was so good it
did yeah for the super bowl party
no what my filipino mom did
twice really yeah my first shark hearing
board is that why people [ __ ] is that
white people something one person did
tweet at me saying it was rich white
people
yeah no
it was also very expensive and i was
like oh my god i spent too much
what
my brain went bad
um
it's
it's uh it's just meat and cheese and
like fruit and olives we've got to make
it pretty yeah can we see it your
pictures oh there was there was one
hiccup which is that you got pitted
olives
i was very flustered because i was i i
volunteered to do it because like my mom
did such a cool one i was like i want to
follow my mom's footsteps my good show
cutery board and then like john was like
make sure you get all of those and i was
like sure thing and then i got all of
some of these had them there and just
started eating literally literally my
first thing i i took a cracker i took
the meat i took the cheese and i put
olive on it
wait wait wait wait like olives have
like really hard yeah olives have seeds
they're pitted so you make them oh yeah
oh that's awesome is that charlotte oh
yeah charlotte's back there too
beautiful
that is really nice you put little
people what did did she have did she
like your chicken board yeah did she say
you were a chicuteri yes it was that was
set a lot i also cut some salami way too
thick oh my god
that's just chunks of meat jacob it was
i was mustard i was trying so hard to
make it look good
but oh boy that does look really good
though wait how do you make a chicory
board you just cut chicken yeah
it was either kate or sam or someone no
i said something
at esque
and we noticed that for some reason
it's almost like a bark when you do it
so
so that's become the everyone's saying
english words
yeah that makes sense to me yeah
we still it's all for everything that's
right merch
like a cup of tea and they keep rocking
this this is because
that's good yeah hey related
to merch we're doing a live show
everybody
oh my god life raffle may not be able to
be there because he's filming um we'll
figure out a way to get him involved but
you can buy tickets and all that i'll
leave a link in the description you can
come see us live in la march 12 i'm
super excited about it i think it'll be
fun i think we should get a mannequin or
like
get a long-sleeve shirt some pants stuff
it with newspaper and stuff
and then put like an ipad or a laptop on
top and then have ruffles skype in yeah
we can make them work yeah absolutely
it'll be terrible for you because you
won't be able to hear anything
but i think it would be great but we
would find it funny yeah that's the
priority what day is it march 12th
what's that it's a saturday what's my
day house oh it's a saturday
[ __ ]
jacob i'll be there great i'm gonna be a
busy boy that day
i've got our podcast and then the
podcast after yeah i'm just gonna be
sitting i'm just gonna be sitting there
on stage hosting an awards show that i
make that day and then going straight to
do a podcast but i think it's going to
be fun i think i'll just be doing that
all day it's podcast should be a good
time it'll be great yeah march 12 we're
going to publish the audio as a patreon
exclusive um not recording any video of
it they don't have to set up to do that
so if you want to check it out if you
can't come in person we'll post it on
patreon
they shaved my whole body
oh that is right you look like me
[Laughter]
everything
i've never even looked before you might
have less hair than i do might just blow
it you just don't grow down there though
i thought no
i don't i
so defensive
no i do that myself but
they shaved me with a with a
trimmer
but
i'm not going to touch it on my balls
i do oh it's okay here no i do razor
blade with
what i tried like
that's scary yeah no it's fine
it's fine you just
i mean it's difficult because you've got
you got to hold the razor and then sorry
and i'm going to hold my dick up what do
you see i don't have enough hands
the other day yeah cause there's no
there's no instructional video so
someone else holds my dick i feel like
she'll be like held out it must be hard
over there oh yeah yeah yeah what what i
we were having a chat the other day that
i feel like shaving balls must be hot
it's not it's super but it's so much
skin it's not
what do you use a lot you use you
literally use a straight razor
no i'll use i think the one the one i
prefer to use is like a mac free
what gillette mac free
and then i just like
i'm sitting there cross side on the
toilet
going as slowly as i can
so what i do is i
i've had more accidents with the with
the ball sack and [ __ ] with a trimmer
that really really and that can be wait
so what is it because that skins can get
trimmed
but you don't use a guard because you
want a zero
yeah you gotta get caught
so that's why people use manscape not
sponsored by them i am how do you use a
short like a full-on razor i'll tell you
you should try it it's it's shave
i've i've done it for a very long time
and i have nev i saw it i saw a porn
documentary once i think and i tried it
and that's how it started but
um
it's it's
it's uh i'll use the trimmer
to
have a nice
groomed pubic area
and then
once i get to dick and balls the trim
stops
if and then i will take care of it if
it's overgrown for whatever reason which
it rarely does then i'll use a trimmer
without it touching my skin to get it
down to a uh you know get close get
close together oh so you should like
shave it like a baby's
face
i just know that a baby is naturally
smooth baby i was thinking of little
rascals will go smooth as a baby's
bottom so so what i'll do is get some
sex shaving foam
i mean girls do it on there you do
full-on yeah so
you get a nice creature
you get a nice um you don't cut yourself
so i'll sit in the bath or i'll stand in
the shower and i'll put shaving foam
around my [ __ ] and i don't know that
girls do that
i think that would be your advice i've
seen it important they use
your own hair
your
clothes
it's like a sensitive
beast i think that if you were to put a
bunch of shaving cream on it it would
hurt
super mild i have i use nivea uh
sensitive shaving foam gel you need to
get all these sponges down so i put it
on and then what i'll do is
i'll pull it taut
so yeah so stretch it out so you start
on this side shove your junk to that
side and work and you have a flat to it
sort of fairly quickly it takes you a
while
no not really but like you want to get
all the wrinkles there there and then
once it's all done
so i'll do the ball set but i'll stop
like i won't it i won't go all the way
down into the gooch i'll stop it and
then and i'll do like the base of the
cot
and what you end up with and then i'll
use like um uh
post shaving um
i'll use post-shaving bomb just in case
there's any type of irritation i have to
shave like that hot stuff
oh spice
but yeah i'll do that and then
[Laughter]
right and let me tell you something
about the gallus yeah when the balls are
that smooth
they can't help us suck them
oh sucking a yeah yeah i always use that
as an insult go suck an egg but it kind
of seems like a nice thing but it's that
smooth a 100 track record
really wow
i need to take that to the bank tea
bagging
that's my advice actually to any of our
listeners if you're in a relationship
and you're
having issues with
foreplay no egg sucking no egg sucking
no ball play
do what i said then test it out it's
like moths to a flame break those
straight razors out boys
i just want to make it it's time to cut
i feel like people probably google micro
penis just to make sure they don't have
one they want to compare well the one
that was like the immediate result oh
that's my food
macaroni
like an hour ago
the one that was the first result um
[Music]
smaller than a gorilla's penis is it how
big is a gorilla's pink i think three
inches of rest how do you know that
jacob
how do you tell me listen
i i know things that's what i do
that's concerning
i've already brought up the hyenas on
something
one podcast we've done you brought it up
on like eight different
places
like that's the re-entry for the edit
okay
okay mac and cheese macaroni let's
[ __ ] go
i have that can i just eat that whole
thing you can have some if you want to
go get a fork go for it my dude you just
wanted like pork
right in your mouth dislocate my jaw
nice
uh john's been cooking for me everybody
it's great huge fan john is the best are
we going again but he did roast me um
regarding my lack of seasoning
i opened the cabinet
the only you're like oh yeah the
seasoning is in the kit this cabinet i
opened it's those little diner
things where it's the salt shake like
the plastic pepper sugars yeah with like
the print on the salt pepper with little
pictures of things
what's wrong with that
it's salt
yeah i guess
pre-ground pepper
okay everyone if we are not cutting this
pre-ground pepper
pre-shredded cheese
and something else
that sounds disgusting
i think it sounds hot you don't want
those because a lot of the flavor
is in the oils in the sense or whatever
and when you shred it up when you cut it
up that stuff will evaporate oh coffee
same with pre-ground coffee really that
stuff will evaporate and you'll lose a
lot of the flavor
yeah oh wait so then what do you do with
salt it's always going to come
no i said pepper you idiot
[Music]
i don't know man i don't do a lot of
interesting cooking my diet's so bland
i just cook myself boil some carrots and
put some honey on it and then i'm like
cool a meal have a lot of actually
it is really nice yeah that sounds like
some it's an easy sort of glazed carrot
situation cut back in welcome back
that's one of my favorite things to make
i make it out of a skyrim cookbook you
said that yeah some some glazed carrots
that's dope dude it's delicious it's so
easy too get some cardamom
i have a witcher cookbook over there
oh really there's a widget cookie oh are
we eating
yeah let's see i am
okay just i mean the mic is over there
so it's not going to pick up like all
those smacking stuff okay
um so what were we talking about before
we came out before we went from like
to micro penis
shavings shavings shaving your bowls
i never thought that you would actually
shave them with a razor i never even
thought so what do you do
i just trimmer and i get as close as i
can so it's all a little bit of short
little like when you're talking you cut
your bowls i'll try it you ever buzz
yourself yeah the buzzer i buzz my balls
all the time the balls are like the
tongue where it heals very fast yeah it
still hurts though yeah it hurts but
then it's pretty much
really never and i've nicked myself with
goatee trimmers
goatee trimmers
streamers beard trimmers whatever people
do they call them goatee trimmers in the
uk
do they he's the only one with a goatee
in fact they do
i'm glad you asked that's the goatee
expert
we really cover all the bases on this
show i once shaved a goatee and i feel
like i looked like a like a
curvy youth pastor
so i'm never gonna shave a goatee ever
again it's a very specific style choice
yeah to have a goatee people some people
it works most of you it doesn't and you
should reconsider your facial hair
effort do you put into like what style
you pick for your facial hair nothing
zero i went too fast this is kind of
what you have this is all i got yeah
there's nothing else oh sweet you're
hippie i shot something
in complete secret
and
um
i
at the time i did it you haven't even
alluded to that one
is it where you put that glass jar up
your ass and then it shatters
but they uh
they brought it up recently the the
bosses
because they were shocked that it just
flew under the radar so so it was never
supposed to be
a super secret but it was like oh well
then
we'll just let it happen like
we won't tell anyone and then when it's
out it's out right i'm very confused as
to what you're talking i did a i did a i
did a roll in something
and it wasn't a secret but i never spoke
about it i never posted about it the
press never said anything about it
probably because no one cares but it
ended up being done the whole thing in
complete secret without any speculation
and no one is
the creators the studio everyone's like
well let's never say anything it's not
star wars it is it's not star wars ezra
it's not star wars [ __ ] you jacob
i apologize
i remember people would like dm me
a month later upset
why like you're not my [ __ ] ezra
basically about
playing it didn't start with you though
other people started it about playing
ezra in
like mandalorians
and um
people took it as confirmation and then
treated him like
no they were mad happy yeah
so what happened was
i was shooting midnight mass i was
watching rebels
and i was going to the gym
now six months prior to that moment
there was a news article i think variety
or vanity fair someone someone or true
hollywood someone broke the
um
so six months prior to that there was a
story that went out that
lucasfilm or whoever were looking for a
south asian actor between the ages of
something like mid 20s to mid early 30s
but it sucks that you're 40.
so you have beef curtains
i'm really defensive about my age i'm so
sorry
thanks i don't have a bottle opener
do you have a lighter i can bottle open
is in that red thing
so anyway
so so that was the that was the news
story and
so
so um
here i am six months later you know i
was going to the gym and i wrote this
tweet because i was watching rebels and
i just wrote oh i'm getting into uh
low full orphan shape
it's really cringey
that's all it was
oh my god who's going to be
i go to the gym i come
my phone's in like the locker
and when i get back it's miss calls text
messages oh no i was like
oh what's that
so i look
and it's
like the tweet blew up in like an hour
and
oh and it was all hype and it was all
excitement oh no and everyone was like
this is the [ __ ] best news ever i
can't believe it it's gonna get
confirmed
and i was like oh no it's not i was like
i don't think i didn't care about ezra
this was like mandalorian hadn't shown
ahsoka yet there was none of that stuff
yeah so
i then recorded immediately and i'm in
the car because i was at the gym i get
into the car and i record a video where
i say hey look this was awesome and i'm
so glad everyone was so enthusiastic but
i'm not playing ezra bridger it was just
a silly tweet
but because i'm a dick
i had the soundtrack playing in the car
and you know what everyone everyone got
it and was like this dude's a [ __ ]
troll he's having fun it's all good for
the rest and then ezra trended that day
on twitter and everyone was super hyped
and that was it and then boss logic dms
me and he's like want to see something
cool oh yeah and i look and it's him
working on an ezra poster of me and i
was like oh this logic holy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] open it just felt good because
boss is like you know so well known i'm
glad that you weren't in the mandalorian
[Laughter]
i'm i'm more upset that i wasn't in
booker boba fett because
i really wanted to be part of the
scooter gang yeah
the very cool scooting game the rascal
gang yeah the rascal gang that's even
better
i don't talk negative about solar
yep so i'm not engaging
in any case we got here because we were
talking about facial hair oh no
wait it isn't it was a
there was another thing
there's another when the bottle's open
who wants the chicken too
it would take you a second to open the
bottle what are you waiting for
they've mixed mild and medium oh oh
one of yours is mild in one i don't i'm
good i just ate a whole thing so why did
i just get you i'm like
right oh there's some wet fries
oh my god cheese fries
this is mine it's squeezier
yeah so anyway
that was that i can't remember what we
were talking about ezra there was a
reason we were talking about shaving
your body no we were oh we were you're
right
so
i then went and did something and shot
something that wasn't star wars you're
right that's when we got it there
and they said what look do you want to
go for when you you know carrying the
character so i sent them a picture of
brad pitt from seven
when i came out of the trailer i looked
like ricky gervais in the office
because i was 30 pounds heavier
backstreet boys
no he's ripped because i was
out of shape he's a chubby boy yeah so
the whole time was that was the gag that
everyone was laughing at it was like i
was like
i had such delusions about how i looked
yeah brad pitt from seven that's the
only thing that looks like one
i want to look like that the hungry guy
from seven
face down in the in the spaghettios oh
no i was thinking the one that's the
opposite where he's in the bed he goes
oh
oh
with the magic trees yeah i don't look
like the guy that got [ __ ] by the
sword or whatever no he did the [ __ ]
that was the problem there's something
for everyone you know yeah that's why
sevens are great it is a good movie
fantastic isn't kevin spacey he's the
bad guy yeah he's a bad guy we're right
with that he's still a phenomenon thank
god he's like a creepo in most of his
roles it makes sense
it really makes sense yeah it all comes
together they tell you maybe you should
sometimes you should just believe it
okay
uh alana owns metal sporks what the [ __ ]
why is that funny it's hilarious
i've never seen a metal fork in my life
i got extra hot
that hit the back yeah you got extra you
got extra hot i just want you all to
know that i'm very worried about the
couch right now
oh my god they're just confused
um so in australia that's called a
splade
what we call them splats
and they're very common why is it
everything you tell us about australia
yeah
yeah and go on it's great thank you
it's called a splayed because you can
cut with the side of it and that i and
you can't pick anything up it's great of
course you can get there
in australia it's called a spizzy wuzzy
does he
split is that like spoon blade yes
what about the fork part yeah it's just
it doesn't fit i think you've named it
wrong i think so you're missing it
that's what we usually
in australia they're called thongs right
the g strings no
they're flip flops
in america we call g strings of g-string
and then thongs of flip-flops so for you
cisco's singing about shoes
yeah yeah brilliant well g string is
different from a thong
why what way a g string oh it's a string
a thong is just the it doesn't go over
the butt it's like a triangle what are
you doing
g-string
they might as well be naked
i like underwear because it has a shape
it's the g when you're going through the
laundry what one time
i like i like normal underwear
because it's gotta look like pantyhose
like [ __ ] collars you see like boxers
like cases
yeah boxers granny pants
everybody shut up what do you think of
pantyhose okay isn't that pantyho like
leggings
or like tights
yeah yeah right
pantyhose is shia tights yeah the whole
way down what's like laundry day granny
panties you know what i'm talking about
like bloomers yeah they just bloomers
there are um girls i know it comes in
different cuts so there's a bikini say
women's
okay yeah
that's not thank you
um bikini cut and then there's boycott
oh sorry they call it boy like um which
is like they're like they're like
whiskers
they're like shorts they're like it's
like a rectangle
oh okay so it's like boxes a boy like a
boy leg but it's still underwear
it's like briefs
yeah
they're all really similar
yeah um where is it
oh what god still got the micro penises
up y'all ever pee through the slit
commandees
don't look at me just because i said
slit
see boy like they just roll straight you
know
straight through okay boy leg
i just want to apologize to everyone
okay
eating is bad at academic plugins we're
eating and yelling over each other i
don't know maybe that's the energy of
the podcast
um i don't know what they want from us
oh if you pee through the gap yeah the
slit have we not spoken about it before
i don't know sometimes things blur
together yeah it's true you just pull
your pants to the side
you go through the hole women love that
oh you pull your pants
i still do what i've done since i was a
kid which is i drop everything and i
still know what it is
when you go to a nightclub i'm just
standing by your own like that what are
you what's the posture are you leaning
on something you bring your chair in
with you you have no idea your hips you
stand you probably you know i'm holding
up my you hold this up you don't have
your shirt under your head
they did that and your hands just hit
everything and everything's on the
ground and you like that and then people
come in and go with someone i don't feel
like you have to be that naked
that's how we all started yeah yeah yeah
except there were a few kids that would
do that through elementary school i was
one of the best
you know you'd
go to the bathroom and some kid you just
see some kid's ass as they're at the
urinal and yeah
the [ __ ] i was one of the first kids in
my social group who figured out the fly
yeah
i was like i'm not doing this no more
through the fly
yep
pull it all down what if you zip up your
dick
great question
what if jacob let's not pretend that
that's an issue for you
i've always wanted to know
what happened
how likely do you think it is that at
some point a man was very drunk and went
to pee and accidentally vomited on his
own dick but i have it probably all the
time i think so too it must happen like
nightly in a hundred thousand different
places i just want to see it so bad i
bet you that every irish
every irishman on the planet has puked
on their own the irishman yes massive
generalization no it's not i would say i
would i would wager that every single
japanese person oh did everyone get
nervous yeah
but no one got nervous with the irish
double standards learning lessons you're
not wrong
are you irish just let me know [ __ ] on
your dick
if you guys could just wait for a second
while we eat and we'll just wait a
minute we'll be back the show will be
back temporarily one of my older
co-stars in the fall of the house of
austria um told me that
i come from a very beautiful country
was it mark hamill
it wasn't england i was like oh that
country
i don't know never been there
you have been there haven't you oh baby
still counts i've never been to the
philippines
yeah we're going to get you there i
don't know it needs a real travel vlog
you're going to be shocked by chikuri
you'll be accepted because you made it
so pretty i'll bring the brie and the
grapes
oh how was that uh that super bowl potty
thing you guys went and like everyone
was very warm yeah oh yeah i got real
dusty it was like it was a fun house
super bowl party effectively yeah yeah
lindsay's place was he okay
she's very bengals oh yeah oh yeah it
was rough for her at the end there yeah
yeah just so much to spare
but spicy game it was fun though uh
i feel like we've with super bowl
commercials now
we all have such a different mentality
towards like yeah we're also jaded yeah
because it's like oh it's another crypto
commercial i bet oh it's scientology oh
well there's a bunch of we didn't see
the commercials at stadium that's right
yeah there's so many crypto commercials
whoa
what have you mark on your face
oh
it's mac and cheese it's a pimple i'm
sorry is it gross oh it looks like a
scratch
i mean it's a pimple that i scratched
thank you for pointing it out
thanks for apologizing
dory we're shooting in 4k so yeah
they'll see it
yeah
if you notice a lot of blemishes hey
wait you'd come on camera exactly it's
as a woman
yeah i don't care about you look i have
a podcast
that was during the super bowl yeah that
was a crypto commercial and devastating
such a weird commercial too there was
like the screensaver one that everyone
was losing their [ __ ] about
screaming
yeah it was one where it's just a qr
code bouncing around the screen like a
dvd screen saver oh that's nice to go
into the corner yeah
it does
the last one of course that's smart yeah
but also crypto
a lot of crypto a lot of crypto a lot of
electric trucks what trailers did we get
we got batman no they did um the
multiverses madness yeah oh doctor
strength
yeah was there any other trailers
i don't know i wasn't paying attention
most of the time either i was really
just standing by all the snacks the
whole time yeah just like eating snacks
from did you eat from your own chicory
report or did you eat other snacks
jacob
you bounced
you did a little bounce
oh god
does anyone want paper towel i'm glad
you're being nice to this
i wish i got like a good recording of
that so i could use it in videos it's
like a fart sound it was really good
pretty
it's
gonna pick up it was isolated
yeah it was like a stock fart
a little trumpet
it's a place
i bought my first one in the show you
got anything else
um i did it in front of mary mcdonald
she was like a legend
i don't know as they got to the end of
the scene i just went
and she went who done that
on the freeway it was it was wrong
you can do that in front of frank
langella yeah
nice i'm not scared of frank
i'm terrified of a prank
put him in his place
i'm terrified
i completely forgot what we were talking
about
when that fart happened
yes
i i ate from my own checked food board
yes
yeah i i don't know what the etiquette
is of going to a party bringing food and
then just eating your own food that's
fine that's fine i mean it's there it's
there for everybody to eat yeah you
always bring too much i felt no it's
only a problem if you don't bring enough
for everyone else yeah yeah so you
bought your own stir fried rice when the
breeze started running low i reached for
it and jacob growled at me
scary stay away from my breathe
brings a great cheese i wrote it on the
little side i don't know i can't be in
the mood for bree sometimes it's a bit
a little too much when you microwave
grease smells like kum
is that true i always got a deli it
feels like there is a [ __ ] something to
it sometimes what is calm smelling like
too melty
yeah it's a pan it smells like [ __ ] i
don't know sometimes it smells like
cleaning like ammonia
i always thought i spelled with you
i always thought it smelled like a pool
like a chlorine pool yeah what is wrong
with the two of you no it's true see
your john is decreed with me it's true
the chlorine have any time have any of
our parents watch this podcast have you
got feedback yeah my parents
i saw the tweet i saw that
message by the way well your mom said i
look like that dude oh yeah oh my god my
mom sent me a picture
of some random
just person of color brown yep yep uh
wearing a mask and glasses and said who
does this look like smiley face and i
just replied not rahul and then she sent
uh
yeah yeah my mom was like hey it's rahul
gilbert he had a beard
but completely masked yeah no features
and a profile yeah yeah
it doesn't make that any other hat yeah
i'm pushing it doesn't look like you
but my parents i asked them about it
because they were in town uh
because i flew in saturday morning
because that was the cheapest flight to
land at like eight in the morning so i
told my parents and they used their
hilton points to get a
a hotel on friday night and then we hung
out all day saturday oh cool and i asked
about i was like you guys still watching
the podcast and they're like we got to
the episode where you talked about
your relations with a prostitute and we
just decided we had to stop
where you came in your dad's pants no no
that one that one that one i told them
not to watch but then after after like
the third episode when it was also
problematic i was like i'm just gonna
let them learn on their own
and they literally got to me in a hotel
banging a prostitute
and my dad said he looked over at my mom
and i was like are you enjoying this and
my mom's like no and they decided to
turn it up
i don't know why because i know that
we're
i picture ye old timey radio
and your parents are sitting with it
and your dad just goes and stands up and
and shuts it off and sits back down it
was basically what happened
i don't know if my parents said i can
see
her
cesareans whatever you were talking
about stitches oh yeah yeah and your dad
just went
to rubber [ __ ]
they're of the lord
they must be confronting
the bulk of the lord yeah sometimes
sometimes family do they just have like
a differently built sense of humor like
i've talked to an uncle at like a family
gathering over the holidays
and
you always will talk to me about how i
can make more money at my job
and it's always like
yeah they push on you eventually yes
yeah it's always like you should like
really get in there like steal rooster
cheats secrets or something i'm like
what do you think she walked like
coca-cola yeah
or something like that none of the
special
one family recipes
who often is like well you didn't share
that with anyone did you like when it
comes to trying to help people you
mentor like six people and they're
always like you can't tell them too much
i'm like i'm not worried about these
people
taking my job no it's not gonna a
problem yeah my one is since the dawn of
like since i decided
this was going to be my career of choice
yeah
um being an actor
particularly in the community that i was
brought up in
it's it's still quite rare in in indian
like south asian families
um
and
so most just shun you but
everyone since wants to have an opinion
and offer advice every unbelievable
acting
but it's so well out of their world yeah
that they would have
they
i've been cliched to death since i was
18. so and um would be like well
it's not what you know in this business
and you're like yeah and they go it's
luck in it it's just luck you get your
big break and it's luck and i have to
validate everyone's because they might
have seen jonathan like a
talk show yeah and they're like you just
got to be in the right place at the
right time right rahul and i go yeah
thanks and they feel like they've helped
because it's an interesting that
everybody sees
well everyone has an opinion yeah what
my grandmother used to do
was she used to
you know you get the papers
you get your newspaper delivery one of
the things my grandma had was and she
was a big fan like supporter of me
um and she supported me when i wanted
when everyone else was a bit unsure and
she on sundays the sunday newspaper
would always come with like a magazine
sunday special
and then if there was ever an actor in
there that was being interviewed and
they spoke about their journey or things
that they did she cut it out
and put it aside for me to
see because she didn't know how to
no one knew like yeah
you should see this agent or maybe have
you tried doing this of exposure no one
really knew so that was her way of going
i remember she had a john hamm one
did you see this john john hamm didn't
make it until he was in his 30s and that
was her way of trying to support me even
though it was so removed yeah yeah
that's very cute makes it relatable
none of my family tried to give me any
advice on my career they have a [ __ ]
idea what's going on now my uncle will
be like yeah like i looked at some of
the stuff you did doesn't really appeal
to me didn't really think it's funny
like multiple
should we talk about it
that's my favorite part about the last
podcast where we kept talking about how
we were going to talk about boba fett
and we never ever did
we talk about star wars generally
actually um before we hit record we
always have a preamble
that's jake fullerton you're pointing it
yep you can't not
when he's in the room
it's true it's his love language a lot
of time i don't even bring it up yeah
but we feel like we should because you
get happy i do get happy well i also i'm
not that happy though i think i told
jacob this that my shtick well the stick
to counterbalance jacob talking about
star wars is that i always act annoyed
by the nerdiness but i actually really
do love all of that stuff and when i was
younger i read through
like the encyclopedias of species and
stuff like that shut up
you showed me those books we did like
the essential guide to yeah yeah
i had those books do you see like the
weapons the i had the weapons the
creatures that's how i knew like when i
watched
my essential guide to droids so i knew
that when i watched the finale i'm like
oh look scorpionec annihilator droids
from call of four
they only made like a hundred of them to
defend uh the colloquoid creationist
homeworld
very uncommon to see them outside of a
call of four control
so i mean hey that's why it's just a big
draetica you know they should have known
that i can't just shoot that shield over
and over
this is what i imagined this is like if
you came up to vancouver
and i introduced you to mark
and you were cool at first and then i go
off for a cigarette and i come back
that's what i expected
at him
where there's a guy who's really
interested to be talking about into the
gallery woman is just like oh my god
trying to escape yeah that'll be me
talking to mark hamill about the color
creation but he's cool with talking
about star wars right he's open to it
i'm out yeah because i know like some
actors who like i mean harrison ford's
the like most well-known example
of being on something that's popular
they just don't want to talk about it
anymore yeah no he's
yeah he's you know he's he he
he knows i'm a star wars fan so he
disarmed me when we first met the first
thing that mark said when wait he
he grabbed you by the shoulder and
flipped you over yeah that's how he
decided yeah yeah
the force pulled the dl44 out of your
hand
nice [ __ ] sake i know you can't be
helped but no i'm upset that i know what
a dl44 is dick yes you should it's han's
gun right yeah yeah um
he
as as i approached him like
we can share this right yeah it's fine
so mike
mike was
so excited about this like knowing how
much mark means to me in the franchise
so i got on set
and
i could tell from mike's energy even
from like his you know his m95 he's like
hey and i could see he's everyone's hype
so it felt it was a really weird like
heightened meeting where the 80s and
everyone was like
have you met him yet is it it felt like
a date it was really like or something
that's what you did i was like no it's
matchmaking but we were you're watching
we were on kevin's podcast
to you it's true it's it's more exciting
for everyone everyone i don't know so
yeah
so finally um trevor macy our producer
was like hey i'll bring you over and
i'll say oh okay cool trying for a beer
call yeah and as i walk over
uh mark looked up at me and he went ah
there's a star wars fan and
it says
oh cause if the squirt is got piss
yeah
that's what you meant that you did yeah
exactly um and then we spent the rest of
the day like it was weird talking to
mark because like he asked me
he was like um
wearing this is the surreal moment he
goes
uh so you're from from england which
part are you from i was like london he
goes which part of london i told him
he was like oh
my um my son's also from london
technically he was born in london
because um well we shot here
and the this was the hospital that was
closest to the studio and he goes that
was when we were doing all the david
stuff
and like
when he says that you want to be like oh
i just said baby
with the green guy the training
muppet right yeah
um but it was he's the best like he he
was one of my
i think i wrote a tweet because it's
true i think you
no
beef clothes
so no so i wrote a tweet that um
because we hear so often now because
we're a shit-talking social media
generation everyone who's ever had a
shitty celebrity or a bad interaction at
a restaurant does a tick-tock where
they're like oh you want to know about
jason statham
he [ __ ] pissed in my mother's face
when he was because we asked for her
pictures and like
so it always does feel like oh these
people are let down i really feel like
ben affleck got done hard there with the
girl that like matched with him on oh
and recorded tomorrow whatever that was
that that that like celebrity tinder
celebrity and so then she was like i
don't believe that you're really ben
affleck so he recorded her a video and
sent it to her on instagram and was like
hey it's really me and she outed him he
wasn't even doing anything wrong i know
and everyone i remember saying
rather than maybe hang out with ben
affleck
you just sold him out for some clout for
tent for fighting he didn't even do it a
week of people going
when you could have just like she was
like i didn't even talk about it yeah
just he didn't do anything wrong didn't
work i didn't hear about it she could
have secured the big bag she secured the
five-minute viral bag oh man
do you think his bag is shaved
eggs
when he was in the i think when he was
in the jennifer lopez music video
it shaved eggs mmm wow
shaved eggs
when he's the cigarette one
remember that one
where he's standing
okay i could look at celebrity and know
if they grew or not do you shave your
bush like raw or do you leave like a
little hedge
are you doing
i would give it a low fade
i don't think oh
sometimes
i've gone really zero
but it looks too like
so hard i've been doing that literally
the whole episode you haven't noticed
once
they're gonna come defend you now yeah
they are because i seem like i'm upset
yeah i'm sorry they're gonna come from
japan
when she's doing the bit people think
you're not doing them not actually come
for me [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
whoa
typing at me from your basement
yeah we'll get back to that hang on
rubble you were telling a story before i
interrupted with ben affleck anecdote
and i don't know what it was
we talked about his eggs oh i was just
saying that we were constantly i think
we're in this world where we're
finding out shitty stories and some a
lot of them are valid absolutely and a
lot of them are terrible and it should
be good that we're holding some people
accountable
but i wanted to share that
i was a fan
who met a hero and it went well it
didn't and it didn't just go well he's
everything you'd hope he is it's funny
to joker with him you can like and he
was just that's awesome i do just dope
and
he must
and if you put yourself in his shoes
like i felt on set
like he is coca-cola famous yeah he's
one of the very few people on this
planet who have who are like mickey
mouse michael jackson mcdonald's yeah
he's luke skywalker
and almost everyone on set
is of the age group that that was their
boyhood hero and he's got to just work
and come to set and every
person who work
is like
hi
i can understand why that might [ __ ] you
off that but he doesn't it's fully
embraces that and is cool with it he
stood up in a scene
it was his it was his uh coverage
um but we were all behind him and it
wasn't just us it was uh there were like
a big room full of background as well
and
while we're waiting and the cameras are
you know speeding up and everything and
everyone's settling down mark's telling
a story about
uh the millennium falcon cockpit
and he's like you know and i'm sitting
there you know there's a guy in a monkey
costume and
you know the coolest guy in the world
smoking a cigarette and and
we're all i look we're all putty in his
hands like everyone might like
he's just he's talking about chewbacca
all right everyone
i had to make a cut here because
somebody on the podcast
asked for me to cut
things from this episode three times
guess who it is
guess who asked it was john
i know you'd think it was rahul based on
what he's talking about right now but it
was john
um and this one's just so awkward the
cuts so abrupt and weird and there was
absolutely no way to fake it so
i just thought i'd come in here and just
tell you all it was john's fault
please send all your angry tweets
directly to at john smith
that is with two fs instead of a th on
the end at j-o-n-s-m-i-f-f
thank you very much
here's the cut back in i guess [ __ ]
hell
anyways there's this place in kansas
city called weird antiques
i suggest everyone go there we if y'all
ever come out and visit yeah
um
we should go there because it's so cool
it's it's like uh have you ever seen
that show american pickers
but there's all that it's basically
these two guys that go to all these
hoarders houses basically all these like
67 year old hoarders that have all this
old [ __ ] from like
the past century
and they find stuff that's actually
worth stuff it's one of those places
where there's just all this crazy [ __ ]
um and they have a whole backyard
junkyard with all these huge signs from
like
you know restaurants and companies that
have been shut down so like all these
yeah it's so cool have you ever watched
antiques roadshow
because that's the famous one yeah i i
remember as a kid i used to love it i
remember as a kid being like what is
this [ __ ] but then i've been seeing
clips online now and i'm like
this is so joking there's some amazing
like some people find some amazing [ __ ]
in their lobster oh yeah granddad's
world war one
perfectly
watched four thousand dollars like this
is good money yeah and um
the other one i used to really enjoy
watching was
storage wars
storage oh yeah where they buy the
storage
or whatever and now it's up for auction
you're not allowed to enter you're not
allowed to dig around and feel and look
bidders it's sight on scene so they
stand
back they reveal it there's no
information it's like no information so
they'll spot like [ __ ] that looks like a
movie prop that's a sword and they'll
they can ascertain like what they if
so you stand back and you're like i
think that's a [ __ ] bike i think
that's a bike there that's gonna be and
they're capping in the head and they bid
and they walk
and then whoever wins opens it and it
could be bust it could be shite like it
was a replica or it's just uh
yeah it looked like it was a motorbike
and it wasn't it was just a fender and a
tire poking out i'm sure it's staged as
well of course it is it's reality tv
it's reality and then they
they'll they're stuck with their lot and
then you see them going to their pawn
shops or their you know whoever it is
that they do and then they tell them
they're like this is worth like 25 grand
yeah and they pay
400 for the storage you know yeah it's
quite good i just saw an article today
that
in that someone doing one of those
storage wars things
found like 250 000 worth of pokemon
cards
just like in storage well i mean i have
all of my original pokemon cards still
at home in australia i had my um
charizard got stolen which is [ __ ]
devastating appreciation
yeah
no it's hundreds of dollars
yeah jacob's just showing us his
he didn't know it's a different one
let's just have a definitely different
one okay
i'm very upset about i have a bulbasaur
and everything still though i need to
find my old pokemon cards i i miss i had
like a big the big binder to look like a
pokedex
but i kind of [ __ ] poke them one i
never had a problem in my life well yeah
we can't be 50. hello had my anxiou from
going to the movie me too yeah no two of
those never looked up what it said in
that ancient language like who gives it
are you saying ancient
ancient john you were talking about
ancient what did you say
so you were talking about that you just
said
yeah so anyway i feel like we need to
address what jacob says
how could i say action
ancient oh my you're saying it like
anxious
[Music]
how often do you have this problem with
destiny
i'm freaking out right now because i
didn't know i've done this
you were saying
anxious ancient ancient ancient ancient
that's right ancient ancient ancient
it's like me with eggs yeah you say egg
yes dan called me out on it when we were
going to lunch like four years ago and i
think about it
literally every time i say
said you say eggs weird eggs i was like
what eggs eggs yeah it is strange my
mom's my mum can't say poem freaking out
right now
poem yeah
how did she say it
and if you ask her she gets more nervous
that's just an accent though
he could only say massage
like you couldn't say massage
[Music]
i can't say
[Music]
i actually like that i i've decided to
adopt it although i i assume nothing so
excuse me i barely ever use it um no
ronald you've got one that you only
recently been able to say that's really
bad shut up what is it compilation yes
compilation you used to say compliation
or something
always flipped and you don't do it
that's not true i don't care
i think that's cute i used to say it
right
and then i somehow forgot how to say it
and then had to re-learn how to say it i
never struggled with compilation that's
how i was like
yeah there's a compilation videos
no it was confirmation is what you would
say complimation that's a different
completely different one it's a
confirmation
is that a word surely not it should be
it sounds like yeah it should be a word
it always means that unrelatedly isn't a
word
i always want to go unrelatedly i've
definitely said that before uh listen
language is
like like gender it's a social construct
so unrelatedly
could be a word now that is true
like
someone this dude alex dodge from high
school what up alex one of the smartest
persons i've ever met
uh
i was like ain't isn't a word where it
was uh
yeah like i ain't gonna do it
um i was like it's not a word and he was
like yes it is
and he explained to me how language is
just
you know it's made up by people so if
people use the word then it's a word
it's definitely a thing where people
what about scrabble
what about oh can you use it
no it was a conjunction or contraction
why can't you use ancient scrabble
because it's a contraction
you can't have an apostrophe like you
couldn't use hasn't played really yeah
you can use hasn't haven't really i'm
yeah because it's two words technically
even though eight
is am not or like
i don't know i think m naught is right
yeah that's in there probably caught
using it in scrabble can you use it in
wordle it's it's five letters no
actually
i think i've tried before
we started doing these in in uh
in colorado i forgot to bring it up that
like i've done it every day since
colorado dude we got some spicy ones
recently yeah
i don't play [ __ ] new york
you don't have a large enough vocabulary
yeah
i did actually i tried punty like two
days ago and i was like come on well
well that's what ryan ryan haley when he
plays wordle
every it'll be four guesses like [ __ ]
penis dicks
and they'll all be wrong and then he'll
get the last word right when he finally
gives up and does something normal
i appreciate it well there's lootal as
well though
made by furniture carry what uh
i like coral because it's basically four
wordles at the same time
what is that
it's you it's literally four wordles at
the same time what does that mean
they're all on there and every word you
guess it guesses it for all of them and
it shows you which ones are correct so
you basically oh that's cool listen we
sound like [ __ ] nerds i slam that
gash
on a regular basis there's another cut
here
still very weird
john
said some stuff and then said the phrase
built a puzzle
i'm catching you up
please direct all complaints to john
smith thank you oh my god it was so fun
i think you build a puzzle unless it's
that 3d puzzle
no it wouldn't be building that would be
like a it's lego a 3d puzzle we placed a
puzzle put a position
assembled we assembled a puzzle i would
say made a puzzle but you're right it's
assembled
no or completed
or completed attempted i finished the
puzzle what did i say built yeah yeah
yeah that's why it was weird there's
like no i build you don't build
miniature are you doing my miniatures or
talking about lego what are you talking
about miniatures okay so along with
along with model kits gundams
lego i wish i all built very muscular
miniatures
come in on spruce for the most part so
you have to assemble at least the arms
if it's warhammer you choose you have to
cut out from a different sprue whatever
configuration you want yeah so same as
gundam
then i painted it twisted for too long
my body hurts you also have to put it on
the base in almost all miniatures you
have to glue to a base so even if it's
mostly pre-built there's usually some
assembly right
so you you always build a miniature then
you paint a miniature sounds very cold
oh god it's so boring i'm listening i
don't know i think it's pretty cool
make sure we're still recording just you
know
we are
cool
love them
you are completely in frame john you can
stay like that if you want okay yeah as
long as you're comfortable he's also
kind of collapsing my throat like this
you want to fry
if you don't know
well yeah here we go put the cheese
fries on his chest give me that one so
you can look really american oh yeah i
forgot about the chips
what how far in are we an hour 35.
should we eat the chips i don't think
this has been a good podcast it's been
chaotic
i feel like this is like an early mega
64 podcast where no regard for the
viewer
yeah no we're really just having a chat
this is great for the audio listener um
oh please don't get that on the couch
great okay good stuff
i'm coming back worked out worked out
welcome back oh my god
should we chip it up inside
yeah i didn't buy myself one because i'm
not doing it um so we got uh rubble
would you like to introduce chips
oh you can't say it
we have the [ __ ] one chip
inside is one extremely hot tortilla
chip i thought it would be fun carolina
can i go to the restroom first is it
carolina or carolina carolina carolina
carolina reaper is it reaper or drooper
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so we have the [ __ ] 2021 yes
which i'm the only one allowed who can
say it
uh one chip challenge from uh carolina
carolina reaper scorpion pepper yep
inside one extremely hot tortilla chip
uh this chip will destroy you
awesome do not eat if you are sensitive
to spicy foods allergic to peppers night
shades or capsicum faster or are
pregnant don't have any medical
conditions keep powdery to children
after touching the chips wash your hands
with no soap and do not touch your ass
with soap sorry and do not touch your
eyes around the sensitive area seek
medical assistance should you experience
difficulty breathing fainting or
extended nausea i feel like i did pretty
good you did you did pretty good that's
really good you can slow down now you're
going too fast
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no it's not dead
you've broken me oh my god
no no no
making eye contact with me in a very
hostile way is that what you think is
yeah so i look away you don't want to
shut her off
she's just people who can't see the dog
looks like this
she looks like she's dead
she's just scoping it i'm not making eye
contact pretty lady
oh you're okay
this is gonna suck this is you no it's
not oh you my dude oh please don't vomit
on my couch that's a lot oh it's in like
a little do you want to tell them about
the last time i ate yeah last time that
donated something hot in front of me he
was in a couch sitting on a couch
directly it's a lollipop right quite
close to my face and immediately folded
it into a bag maybe this far from my
house maybe about like three inches from
my face it stanks so that it was so
stinky in my defense
i had eaten like six pounds of
mcdonald's and was stuffed to the right
of mcdonald's yeah yeah yeah
i was in a different place in my life
where i would encourage myself and then
regret it
it was before i was allowed in content
who's who said you went around i'm just
joking say that name
[Laughter]
all right
what to expect was it someone i love
deeply round one
what is this yeah what does it say
what are these rounds it says what to
expect okay should i read this no oh
it's written as like a boxing match or
something this is dumb it's you a mere
mortal who thinks they have what it
takes versus the reef reaper
one of the pieces what one otherworldly
demon fueled by the hottest peppers
known to man what to expect oh we have a
timer spicy punch versus a scorpion
sting a vision disruptor why does it
cost 30 minutes and then roast i'll read
it i'll read it okay so what we have
here is a a timer for a challenge feel
so uh you have to see how long you can
go without eating or drinking anything
five minutes is powerless 10 minutes is
powerful 30 minutes is supercharged and
one hour is invincible it's black
without drinking you have to see how
long you can go without eating or
drinking anything what
i have a [ __ ] loaded up in my rectum
that i'm planning on doing immediately
after the podcast yeah
i feel like this is a bad idea how
loaded
really like poking through yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
like if you if you release any pressure
you're gonna [ __ ] your pants it's like a
little turtle head oh my god okay so at
first it'll just be a bit spicy second
little i don't know scorpion the third
is your vision will get shitty and then
your gut will hurt and then it's done my
vision will get shitty yeah it's just
vision disruption i'm getting this on a
shirt
we'll see i just destroyed we will see
yeah i feel like a lot of my comments
i get a like a one of those you know
when someone tells a joke that's not
funny
and you just kind of like look out
and then move on
i feel like any time i say anything
rubble kind of goes
and then
this whole podcast
i'm very excited i'm just not on oh it
looks like [ __ ] it is color like poopy
do you eat the whole chip mine's in
three pieces but i'll do my darndest
yeah can you smell that put it on
it doesn't smell good
it feels like it's going to taste not
nice i feel like it might not taste good
it smells like kind of like i really
like spicy stuff as long as it tastes
good it's smells like why are you
smashing it
so that i can put multiple bites in my
charcuterie report i had habanero jelly
i'm just gonna i love you so much are
you gonna do the whole chopino
delicious i'm doing the whole chip i
just my mouth doesn't go that big
i got the bsl i got small lips
okay let me know when you're ready
should we do it yeah are you going to
start the timer touch your eyes or
anything
not protecting because i don't need
spicy food in this
i have to make it through any of this
for the record everybody mm-hmm
i don't do it
these are stale
yeah oh they're stale
everybody seems fine so far
john john's like weirdly choking a
little bit
how's it going does anybody have any
commentary
it's a lot of silence
a lot of silence
um
yeah can i watch my hands so that sure
yeah
okay there's coughing happening why is
coughing happening
this is extremely unpleasant yeah oh
it's super unpleasant oh it's started
ah
oh can you explain what's happening this
mountain
it tastes like ass just fine
sweating
oh god
wow you look like you're in pain jacob
is that bad
[Laughter]
ah oh wow okay it's been a minute oh
rubble's getting sweaty
not very much though unfortunately
john how are you feeling i'm feeling
great
i don't know what's happening my ears
are
your ears are stinging
yeah you you can see the sweat on your
face you all have watery eyes
a lot of buffing
you're right that this is going to lead
to the end because everybody's just
sitting in silence
so star wars
jacob don't you dare drink out of that
toilet
so it's gonna get worse
yeah yeah
wow
can i um interview you yeah uh rubble
what's the your favorite city you've
ever visited london why
i don't know
john um what is your first childhood
memory
walking
just walking when i learned to walk you
can remember that yeah
really
yeah i'm quiet look
jacob what's your social media look i'm
crying
oh my god
[Laughter]
you did it's kind of horrific
jacob you okay i'm good yeah okay are
you doing wiring now
[ __ ] packies
i'm very proud that you all did it um i
don't know what you do all right i'm
sweating so bad i feel dizzy you guys
are gonna think this is very funny when
you watch it back is all i'm saying yeah
hello i got here oh hey uh-huh um jacob
uh i'm okay what
uh how far is your favorite movie as a
kid
five will go to the west
what did you say
final
five american tale
finally
what was it like when you first booked a
zombie
best day
[Music]
um when did you start working for
non-profits
i hate i i had no interest in working
for non-profits
i think non-profits are predatory go
back down i'm ready to work yeah just in
case
oh god i'll be right back
they're all scams
are they yeah oh that's okay i work for
many non-profits they're all [ __ ]
scammed they're both in scams
i feel like a pepper spray what did you
while standing he was fully upright
don't i don't want to hear you throw up
i don't want to deal with this anymore
you can you can quit whenever you want
my stomach is in pain yeah they said
that would happen
oh my gosh
you if you need anything i can get you
crying
oh my god i haven't stopped crying in
like five minutes
i'm gonna go throw up okay you can go
upstairs if you want oh in the kitchen
that's fine too
are you gonna throw up
you okay
you're crying it's all over your face
oh my god
wow okay this is pretty bad then huh you
guys you all made five minutes
you made five minutes i'm okay yeah
you've been through worse
you need a lot of hot food
[Music]
i mean i've got burps yeah
oh jake john's peeking
yeah i've got the butt why does it make
you throw up i think i could do hot ones
this is worse than hot ones it's you
know so the chip when i put it in i put
it in hole
did it give me a joke or smile yeah of
course these corners are on fire oh
where it touched your mouth where i
punched it there but apart from that i
feel like okay
like oh my god oh it's good
you can talk
it's better than the others yeah the
boys are puking
you can just hear
for our audio listeners you can just
hear
he has to be doing that for the bit
there's no way he's actually vomiting
like that
oh my god
so one chip challenge they've cheated
right have i won
can i have a sip yet
i don't i think jacob's probably had
some they've got tap running that's true
i don't think john does
i don't it's hard to say jacob have you
heard have you interacted with water
sorry
have you had water should have kept your
excuse been pepper
why are you getting mad at jacob you
know him
oh my god okay you made seven minutes
do you need milk
the thought of not being with you
i can't breathe you couldn't even do
that
oh my god over here
the track
of darth vader
but you made it through that
no oh my god ralph you're just fine now
yeah i mean i'm i've got content
yeah i thought well i'm okay okay that's
impressive just seven minutes if i drink
it's our choice
i could try and not drink for the rest
of the till we finish did you make it
have you had have you had a have you had
a drink yeah he's drank tap water so
he's big
i've never thrown up with that before
okay jacob he's in pain but john you
have to look at jacob
he made the dog pop he did make the dog
box
are you okay bud you have happy water in
it
you can have milk now if you want yeah
she's
she's she's really pretty confused
there's a lot going on yeah you won't
milk jacob
okay you're not gonna die
okay if it would kill you it'd be
illegal
are you gonna need a milgram hole
no you could
i should order more milk in it um
yeah rubble you just you might just make
it through you're at uh 8 30.
it's up to you mate
what's all that water on the ground
there's water on the ground is that my
drawer no i could have been did you
splash your face no
jacob's tears from you i think mate it
could be jacob's tears somehow did you
wear yourself
oh my god i'm so scared you're gonna
vomit in my face again no i'm good
making
to be surrounded by three
faults so bodily fluid i'm very aroused
it's doing gross
wow
the cheese i'm falling down my face
this is very dramatic
i respect it
i also need to pee i'm worried
not because i had to but i didn't want
my entire insides to burn for the next
12 hours
so i decided to throw up
it was my own choice
i know i
was perfectly upright what came out of
me this was
a toilet completely upright it was like
oh
something that something that did happen
though was on maybe my third heave it
did that it splashed and then splattered
all over my face
luckily it didn't go into my eyes
went into your face
my throw up
oh
my god is that worse than coming in your
mouth
i've come in my face so many times on
accident how i've done that yeah
hand jobs man oh well other people did
it not yet yeah i just i just forgot to
yeah
all right well um no we should go
have any more questions this is a good
bit they seem so vulnerable we can ask
them questions ask me whatever you want
10 minutes jacob what do you do do you
like the sequel trilogy no it sucks
he's told me the truth no but why do you
hate him
long ago
i too was
the bright eyed bushy tailed
star wars fan
taking on his deathbed jacob have you
ever been pegged
not yet
i watched force awakens filled with
optimism
oh you were yeah
first time around
even the last jedi
when it came oh
i found this oh i just got my made wave
come back to you okay
and then rubble you're on you're on 11
minutes and then
oh i don't need it i watch friends with
skywalker
whereas skywalker was so bad
it made me hate the other two movies it
is bad yeah
she likes welsh
the only thing that's discomforting is
where i stupidly slammed the tortilla
chip straight into the corners of my
mouth yeah
but
i'm fine
i'm fine sweats have stopped i'm so
fluent i too am fine
you both look like you've been pepper
sprayed and you do you look like you've
been touched
you don't like those people at the
protest like you were
i don't know what i'm going to pour the
milk in my eyes please don't do that
that's old milk by the way it's white
they roll no it expires in
in five days it expires on eldon ring
release date oh i'm so excited for
elderberry it's gonna be great it's
gonna be great
we're gonna have a great time you get
that email jacob dies today
just before
on his deathbed before destiny and ellen
hey
where's my phone
it was just recording the podcast you
[ __ ] was wish
yes it was the best jacob you played a
peanut butter it would be better if i
said no
i'm filipino yeah
i should be here
the philippine filipino um
away
are you at me
don't filipinos like spicy food
isaac's sale are you exactly making
chocolate reports what does he know well
this is the curse right they had us laid
upon me yeah the white side of the
family
the white side i apologize
because
what was really bad for you by the way
really yeah
so the reason is is because it creates
it's oil
chili is an oil
so when you drink water it just squashes
around yeah have milk you'll feel a lot
better or if you can as
you have bread
yeah i got some bread if you just eat a
slice of bread my mustache is full of uh
mucus and i got a lot of that in the
milk
i'm going to melt delicious
is the milk helping
you're sweating
less don't really sweat it all i just
pulled that i love american milk because
they pump it up
jacob's getting is cold
we're losing jacob i'm so cold
he's fading fast i haven't sweat at all
i've just cried
do you want some bread there's a white
bread from the
thing
the thing is
hey everybody stop sweating you can
remember the shire mr frodo
i'm actually pretty fine now rosie
okay i should probably wipe my nose
she had flowers in her hair
if i were to marry anyone
i was joking about the mucus another
very good performance it would have been
our
it would have been our
my nose is bleeding what my nose is oh
my god holy [ __ ] john's bleeding out of
his nose
oh my god
oh my god
i gave you a nosebleed
yeah
i feel bad
feels like a really good place to cut
anything else
no that's yeah
what other death scenes was that star
wars death scene what about uh do you
think that's the hobbit
how about how about leia
luke
oh easy
no easy talker
uh
luke
[Music]
um thank you everybody for watching when
do i take water because i want to get
this hour i want the hour well then
you've got
45 minutes
it's been 15. i mean if i took water
it's water doesn't help no if it makes
it worse but like it's short-term gain i
know
this challenge you never drink water no
no no i know but where was this whole
idea of the time limits uh on there yeah
okay so
i don't need water i'm completely fine i
think you should sit with it
how do we
let them know that i did the full hour
which is in that i'm invincible i'll add
it in post
i'll add it in post i had a little
and raffle made it we'll do like one of
those like
just having a scratch
just scratching yourself shut up [ __ ]
hey
she's a female book right yeah i know
she shut up she's probably pregnant a
technicality what have you done well i
had like a one it's like
it's like
the end of the movie in the 80s where
it's like and rahul made it the full
hour jacob was never seen again
oh that's a great one yeah
we'll do it [ __ ] his pants
um i did i'm sitting in my own phone oh
no you had a nice video thank you
everybody for watching the next episode
we'll publish on april 4th but remember
we're also doing a live show
on march 12th if you want to come
through i'll leave a link in the
description i'll see you there thank you
to everybody on patreon for supporting
the show
you sound like anything now oh we didn't
we didn't clap but i guess we don't need
to because there's camera audio
[Music]
do
do
you